let's now tackle the rest of this
problem so they say a light bulb is
non-ohmic if its resistance changes as a
function of current you're set up from
Part A which we have right over here is
to be used or modified to determine
whether the light bulb is non ohmic how
if at all does the setup need to be
modified well we want to be able to
change the current that's going through
the light bulb and then see how the
resistance changes so what we could do
we can always measure with the setup
right over here it's very easy to
measure the resistance so we can measure
resistance by we know that V is equal to
we know that voltage is equal to current
times resistance or that resistance is
equal to voltage divided by current so
if we know the current going through a
light bulb and we know the voltage
across it we can always figure out the
resistance of the light bulb so our
setup right here is actually very good
for figuring out the resistance of the
actual light bulb and so we need to
change the current and see how the
resistance changes and there's a couple
of ways that we could change the current
we could change some other resistance
here but lucky for us we have a variable
power source so we can change the
voltage we could change the voltage
across the entire circuit and by
changing the voltage across the entire
circuit well that's going to change the
current that is going this is a simple
circuit it's just going in series the
current is just doing like that
and so if we change the current through
the entire circuit we would be changing
the current through the light bulb and
then we can just measure V and I and
figure out whether R changes as well so
how if all does the setup need to be
modified I could say it doesn't need to
be modified doesn't need modification
modification alright and then the next
section what additional data if any
would need to be collected well I would
want to I would want to measure let me
do this part down let me do it part C
over here so Part C so part one of Part
C was no modification no
modification Nomad I can explain that
I can change resistance or I can change
I can change current by varying power
source by varying power source power
source I can measure I can measure
resistance of bulb by voltage across
bulb across bulb divided by divided by
current entering or exiting bulb and I
know the first part of this test we were
saying hey do we have the same number of
electrons per second entering the bulb
or exiting the bulb but from what we
know of currents we know that the
current is going to be the same on
either side that you have a voltage drop
but the current is the same and so
entering or exiting you're going to get
the same value and even if you didn't
know what I just told you the first part
of the experiment would have told you
that that your courage is the same
entering and exiting the bulb and so
this right over here is going to be
equal to the resistance of the bulb so I
can change I can change the current by
varying the power source and then as I
can see what value I get for R by
measuring these things as I change that
overall current for my for my platform
for my setup
let's see B what additional data if any
would need to be collected so part two
part two here I need to collect collect
voltage across across bulb as as current
changes or maybe as I change my variable
power source as
very power source power source and I
would also have to collect we've already
this way I'll collect that voltage
alright like that voltage across bulb is
a very power source and I could say
current current entering exiting bulb as
I vary power source power source so I'd
have to measure these things and then
I'll be able to figure out if my R
changes alright let's tackle Part D now
how would you analyze the data to
determine whether the bulb is non ohmic
include a discussion of how the
uncertainties in the voltmeters and
ammeters would affect your argument for
concluding whether the resistance is non
ohmic well I explained it a little bit
well up here but I'll write it again D
so let me read that one more time how
would you analyze the data so what I
would do is so power source I would make
one voltage for I would very power
source source to first voltage voltage
and measure measure what is described
above and measure above use to calculate
use to calculate the resistance
resistance of bulb and then vary power
source to second voltage
voltage and once again measure above
measure above see if resistance changes
see if resistance changes so we could
say if V across bulb across bulb over
let me actually just write it this way
all the V's are crossed above this v1
over the current one so this is a
voltage across the bulb over the current
across the bulb if this is equal to
after I change it I the voltage across
the bulb divided by the current across
the bulb if this over here if these are
equal then I am dealing with the
resistance has not changed and so we
could say well non ohmic non ohmic is
when the resistance does change if
resistance so we could say non non ohmic
so I could or I could say not non ohmic
non ohmic otherwise if v1 over I 1 does
not equal let me write that our VI v1 v1
over i 1 does not equal v2 over I 2 then
we are non ohmic and we have to be
careful because the sensitivities of our
of our voltmeters and ammeters might
give us an aberrant result for example
we might be non ohmic but because of how
we're rounding in the measurement it
actually might give us a change
especially because our ammeter is more
sensitive here and on the other hand we
might be a situation where we are non
ohmic but it doesn't you don't register
the change because it hasn't been large
enough to be registered by the
sensitivity of your instruments so need
to be careful careful about
about instrument sensitivity instrument
sensitivity sensitivity the rounding
rounding to nearest nearest 0.1 volt or
0.01 amp could result in in difference
in V over I when there isn't any
there isn't any or vice versa it might
not result in a difference but there
actually might be a change but it's not
big enough to be measured or vice versa
so you always have to be careful when
you're doing any experiment in any signs
about how sensitive your actual
instruments are and what the rounding
might do for these calculations